American troops ordered to be ready to
deploy as Israel prepares for a ground
invasion of Gaza that could begin at any
moment Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
putting select US forces on standby
saying they have 24 hours notice should
Israel need them the Wall Street Journal
reporting that around 2,000 troops could
be tasked with advising and medical
support and would not have combat roles
and as that news breaks this afternoon
the fighting continues to rage between
Israel and Hamas for a 10th straight
today Israeli forces is striking the
terrorists from the air and Iranian
backed terror group Hezbollah has been
firing at Israeli military bases along
its border with Lebanon Iran has been
threatening to intervene if Israel goes
through with their ground offensive in
Gaza but President Biden says tyon
better not do
it is Iran behind the Gaza War I don't
want to get into classified information
but to be very blunt with you there is
no clear evidence of that Iran
constantly supports
Hamas and Hezbollah I don't mean that
but in terms of were they did they have
for knowledge did they help plan the
attack there there's no evidence of that
at this point what is your message to
Hezbollah and its backer Iran
don't don't don't don't been Netanyahu
directly linking Iran to the Hamas
Terror attacks Hamas is an AIS of evil
ofah Hamas and Iran
and those who do work for them their
goal is to destroy Israel and murder us
all and as Israel perhaps an allout
assault on Hamas President Biden is now
calling for some restraint do you
believe that Hamas must be eliminated
entirely yes I do but there needs to be
a Palestinian Authority there needs to
be a a path to a Palestinian state would
you support Israeli occupation of Gaza
at this point I think it'd be a big
mistake look what happened in Gaza in my
view is Hamas and the extreme elements
of Mamas Don't represent all the
Palestinian people and of course we have
over 30 Americans killed in this attack
Jesse and there are Americans amongst
the 200 hostages that are be still being
held is p the president or is Joe Biden
the president and why is Pelle jumping
in in these answers and trying to fill
words into the president's mouth let the
president say what he means when he says
don't why is he jumping down the guy's
throat and like helping them out I want
to hear from the president I don't want
to hear from p uh I don't think we can
have a Palestinian State at this point
I've had it with the Palestinians I've
given up on the Palestinians if I was in
Israel I wouldn't be talking about a
Palestinian state right now I don't
think Joe Biden should be talking about
a Palestinian state right now and I
don't like how people tried to
differentiate between the Palestinians
and Hamas to me I see people with guns
that's Hamas the people without the guns
are the Palestinians they believe the
same thing the Palestinians hire Hamas
to run their government you pull them
they all love killing Jews it's in their
Charter they say they believe in suicide
bombings every time a Palestinian
refugee goes to another country it
doesn't work out so well for the other
country and for those Palestinians no
one wants them you don't see Egypt
opening up their doors you don't see
Jordan opening up you don't see the
Saudis why don't they want the
Palestinians Dana I think we all know
why they don't want the Palestinians and
it's not working out having these
Palestinians and Hamas right next door
to the Israelis so time is running out
for Netanyahu I don't know why they're
taking so long with this ground
defensive I would have struck obviously
I have no military experience but I'm
talking about there's a certain amount
of Goodwill that's built up there's a
certain amount of political Capital that
the West will allow Netanyahu in the
wake of this horrific
attack every day that goes by and they
don't move in on the ground and root out
these terrorists and their little
Labyrinth under and and the command of
control the decapitation strikes it's
another day where the United Nations
where the Arab League and some of these
skittish uh American politicians are
going to say you know what let's have a
ceas fire let's let's just wait you know
let's stop let's just stop and if they
don't go in hard and they don't go in
decisively and they don't have the time
to go in and root out these terrorists
then they're not going to do it and then
we're going to be back again five years
later there's going to be another
horrific attack here now Joe Biden has
to put a stronger point on the Iran deal
why can't he say that the intelligence
shows that they had pre-planned
knowledge and probably a hand in the
attack because I don't believe him when
he says that there's no intelligence
pointing to that notice the language he
used Danna he said there's no clear
intelligence so he's couching it he
doesn't want to say it because that
means he has to deal with it and that
means he's responsible for it since
we've been funding this stupid country
for that long I don't like the way this
commander-in-chief has handled this
entire thing and I don't feel very
comfortable now we have a land war in
Europe and we have another hot war in
the mid East and we have a wide open
border and he's sitting back and and he
just saying don't don't what Joe don't
what and there's a possibility judge of
another front in the north on the border
with Hezbollah I'm sorry with Lebanon
where Hezbollah is really dug in deep
right right and uh the Israelis in fact
are uh evacuating some of the Israelis
in the north uh because of the attack
from Hezbollah uh look look there first
of all let's get one thing straight okay
I don't care what Joe Biden says all
right whether or not uh is Israel does
not want Gaza they made it clear within
a few days of this attack by Hamas all
right they don't want it so Joe Biden
don't even comment about it you've got
nothing to do with it secondly the the
distinction between Hamas and the
Palestinians and last week I talked
about the history of Palestine I talked
about the fact that no other uh Arab
country wants them but right now uh they
say a million Palestines have moved from
Palestinians have moved from the
northern part of Gaza and are moving
down toward the South they're trying the
Israel is trying to negotiate in the
United States with Egypt to let some of
them in okay you you can't really
compare all of them to Hamas you really
can't uh and believe me I am no
sympathizer here in fact I would say
bomb them bomb them and then bomb them
again but you've got to understand that
we're dealing with the kind of uh
prepping the battlefield this is a
different kind of Battlefield this is a
country where there are tunnels
underneath some of these tunnels they
cannot be struck but from the air you've
got to go in there and this is the most
dangerous Urban kind of warfare so we
don't know what they've been doing Jesse
and with things that are you know with a
lot of the communications down they
literally have Runners going in some are
Arabs some are some are the Jews trying
to find out what's going on and where
everyone is is is located now so there
was a pause today it wasn't a pause for
the weather Maybe was a pause because
Hamas said don't bomb us and maybe we'll
give you the hostages back I don't think
that's the case I think the P the pause
according to the information I get is a
tactical pause machines people need
arrest constant activities you're
loading bombs fueling you're getting new
pilots in uh but they're going in and
they're going in hard they know that
they that their uh that their existence
depends on this and let's be real clear
under Trump they he they he broke down
and made sure that they went broke as it
relates relateded to the sanctions under
Biden he comes in he lets them get all
kinds of oil revenues and the reason he
can't say Iran is behind it is because
he doesn't want to get into World War II
with Iran that's what's going on there
because somebody's going to drop a nuke
here I don't know who it is but I don't
want to watch it Harold over the weekend
there was a lot of talk about and
concern about a humanitarian crisis in
Gaza then we find out this morning that
yesterday the UN relief was sent in with
fuel and medical supplies for the
Palestinians in Gaza and it was stolen
by
Hamas so we shouldn't be surprised by
any of that it's good to be back hope
everybody had a good weekend the the
world is is a dangerous place and our
our our presence and and and involvement
is is essential to the stability to
Bringing about stability and peace I I
took your comments Jesse uh at heart and
I understand where where you may be
coming from but I would align probably
more with the judge on some of the some
of the concerns and and you you
particularly mentioned the Palestinians
and amas uh it is it is probably easy
and and maybe likelier to conflate the
two but I think you have to separate the
two because I don't think everyone
everyone is in Hamas to this is what we
tried to talk about last week when I was
saying that I listened to the president
and I was not understood where he's
coming from and gave him the benefit of
the doubt because the World War III
option is a very serious option
obviously uh and if indeed there is an
invasion from the northern border on
with the Lebanese uh Israeli border
you're likely not only to need those
2,000 soldiers or troops that they've uh
or that the that the orders have been
deployment orders have been given to by
secretary Austin you may need more my
sources tell me that much of that is for
for Pilots to be able to provide air
support but judge you raised the point
that's been raised over the weekend I
got to tell you this Trey Yanks at Fox
is unbelievable I mean the reporting
this guy's doing uh is and John Rob
really the whole team over there has
been has been has been great but this is
been this is being this is happening in
tunnels I mean this fighting is
happening underground this is a new kind
of fighting when you think about uh the
Coalition that George HW Bush built in
Kuwait you think about the Coalition
that George W bush uh did with with
Afghanistan and even Iraq that's what
President Biden is trying to do here two
we don't do well in as as much as since
World War II in ground Wars we have all
the technology in the world no one can
beat us in that but this kind of warfare
underground we've never done before
right so I think we've got to think long
and hard about if we do go in and level
Gaza
what does that mean how do you do that
number one and two if and when you do do
it do the Israelis then own Gaza are
they responsible for uh the Palestinian
people or those who don't leave so I
think there are a number of questions
that that have not been answered and I
give President Biden a lot more credit
uh in terms of his thoughtfulness around
this issue right before we came on Greg
you can talk about anything you want but
I would just mention that it was been
curious that there's been no sort of
proof of life videos or photographs uh
there was one today they finally
released one of a 24-year-old woman who
has being held hostage she was Israeli
they did not show any Americans but the
Americans are on all of our minds as
they figure out if they can try to find
them Greg last word to you yeah I I you
know I I notice how the media is pulling
us into this innan back and forth game
which is meant to prevent Israel from
EXA exacting Justice in an appropriate
response so a sensible person will say
Israel must go in there track down and
kill Hamas and then the media will say
but innocent people will be killed and
you You would reply that's not the goal
our goal is to go after Hamas and then
the media will say but look at the
destruction and then you say but that's
because Hamas has placed themselves
among citizens and civilians that's on
them and then the media will say look at
these atrocities and then you go again
we aren't interested in collateral
damage that's on Hamas we just want to
get those people responsible for for for
the atrocity that was committed against
us and then they will say and they are
saying this now but it's not
proportional and that's what they're
going to be saying and your only
response is it's War you know and it and
right now you know Israel has to restore
its equilibrium by exacting the
appropriate Justice and we should look
forward Harold you going what's next and
I think that's the big question what is
next in the post Hamas landscape how can
this be fixed can we now start over Okay
if Hamas is no longer there that you
still have Hezbollah but can we start
over will there be other Arab countries
that decide to cooperate together and
take the lead with Israel to rebuild
this region I mean we accept what must
be done beforehand and it's going to be
Grim there's going to be risks in this
war it's going to be ugly but unlike
Hamas Israel is not intending to hurt
innocent civilians this is not two sides
of the same coin all they're trying to
do is exact Justice by eradicating an
evil that was bent on destroying them so
in a way I mean I I feel like you should
we should step back and look ahead what
what's done is is done this is going to
move forward and now we have to start
thinking about well what's
next indeed hi everyone I'm Brian kilme
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now